have you ever thought about cheating on
me you joke about all that I do I always
joke about it with your friends what
what did I just hear bro please if you
guys want support these videos like
comment it helps us with algorithm
really helps to grow this channel come
pop I'm Brian I'm Theresa I'm Troy how
long have you guys been together just
over a year and a half almost six years
now seven years no my like parents are
kind of like instill that into me I want
to like make sure I can trust the person
I'm with and that like he's with me like
for me even if the topic comes up she
gets a little like nervous we used to
have in high school but then I don't
know my body just decided that it didn't
want to anymore I still want to which
one of us has a harder time not having
that's crazy
that's me yeah that'd be me problem it
bugged me about myself at first because
I was like what's wrong with me I was
worried that you would maybe not be
interested in me anymore but then I
realized that you loved me and that was
all that really mattered I'm gonna be
honest with you guys there's something
about those two that seems off yeah
what would it take for you guys today or
for marriage
you'd have to go to my parents and ask
their permission I'll ask that today oh
my god that's gross she Indian yeah
that's a South Asian thing no she's
Indian she could be Bengali I'm not sure
okay listen I know everyone's got their
marriages set up differently but the
idea of having to ask parents to I can
understand marriage was she joking with
you serious with that I don't think she
was really serious I'm just gonna based
off as you said yeah I don't even know I
don't know if they'd be like laughs or
like angry I have no idea I think you'll
say yes do you fantasize about me when
I think it was a very straightforward
question for me I don't I'm afraid so
not really attractive to humans
did he say sorry lady
put it back do you want to confirm nope
I don't like dunking perms yeah the
world is a very vast place that's all
I'm gonna say you caught me watching
I'll be excited this guy wants to do it
so bad it's so bad
what'd you do I would be excited man
that's Chris I don't matter I don't do
you don't believe it
I just don't know how you don't I don't
feel like turned on doing it to myself I
mean it's different for girls we don't
have like anything to I'm like am there
something you don't have you got things
all right there's things happening men
don't have to have owners to be excited
to be clear so you didn't want to do it
and not be hard
same woman would you say you guys are
each other's physical types you feel
pretty attracted to each other that part
of the relationship feels good
yeah I'm attracted I don't know she can
say the same it doesn't matter
Oh I mean even if you're one of those
people who said like I know a physical
body is not that important for me to
hear that from your partner that they
were not attracted to you bro you should
you should walk away no amount of
culture and nonsense is going to get you
what you need from her you can't you
can't overcome everything yeah you look
like me okay whatever but it's not about
how I feel about you it's not about
anything like that it's just this is all
I guess he's definitely impossible in
the game I mean chef explored that that
is possibility what's the craziest thing
you've ever done specially with someone
other than me yeah have you ever thought
about leaving me because my stride is
too low yes yes yes says no I'd be very
shocked
not really it's a lie it's confirmed
everything was a lie about that like
it's just it's hard not not doing it but
I don't think that I'd be worth
believing you for it's not like it's
affecting us it's not like an issue that
comes up it's just it's not like it's
affecting you but clearly he's affected
stop it and it's stuff that you can't
see it to be in relation with someone
not be able to empathize with their
because he's empathizing with you and
he's tolerating it and he's trying to
find it because he wants to be with you
the fact that you're sitting there it's
not affecting us there's something it
isn't that gross that's weird it is
right the same way that if you saw
somebody was that was sleeping with
someone who didn't want to that would
also be gross - have you ever thought
about cheating on me I have not though I
have had an ex-boyfriend contact me and
try and get me - I've never told you
that was a fun thing to learn just now
but I immediately shot it down and
deleted his number because that wasn't
where I was about have you ever thought
about cheating on me you joke about all
of it I do I always joke about it with
your friends what what did I just hear
bro this rod is bugging man I haven't
been this shocked since I watched
Candace over this video what did I just
hear
[ __ ] yo someone in the comments try to
explain leave a comment at this time
step and tell me if you understand what
you just heard
whoa I joke with it with your friends
all the time
did I hear that right any of his friends
are saying oh I'm like you know I could
have him if I wanted you know like how
do you like those jokes I think I think
I can tolerate you I don't know if there
was this girl's test this dude is so
this this dude is so whipped she's
constantly putting him down that's gross
B that's gross and I'm someone was
pretty open with the relationships I
have in I'm pretty fun with the girls
I'm with and then having jokes but this
that's just straight-up disrespect this
water is good yeah I could have any one
of your friends if I wanted to okay then
go no I was just joking don't be making
jokes like that what did you talk about
you think if I saw if I was dating a
girl and I saw her homegirls I bet Mac a
call you can unacceptable so even if you
can that's a gross thing to say to
somebody's active or which of my friends
that's what I want to know what you're
my friend so you're trying to cheat with
she doesn't have too many friends so yes
you're starting to win you ride the bull
by the horns and get free you know what
my brother get free they don't have cows
they don't have their hovels in India he
can't touch them
no exactly yes somewhere the cows
yeah back ow she does seem like doctors
she can't be touched
would you ever consider having an open
relationship if it may
you happy I probably consider it hold up
there would be something really weird
about having an open relationship with
somebody who doesn't want to sleep with
you but wants to sleep with other people
I don't see how that would function this
is not weird that's weird right if you
seriously asked me I'd be like no you
can go like we can break up and you can
all you want but I guarantee you at this
man after this video left her and went
to go start bang she would come running
anybody petty enough to make jokes like
that about his friends would not be able
to handle that kind of emotional ego
blow of a man being like oh yeah peace
and then going to man because she has
you under her thumb the fact that you
just left do you think we'll always be
together yeah I think at this point
you're just waiting for a shiny ring
you're stuck with me there's no going
back
why do you love me we actually both
don't know there's always the minor
things you know like of course we find
each other cute and things like that but
at the same time it's just those are
surface level though the real deep
questions no I don't know why I just
love her why do you love me
um great question I love the way your
mind works
I love how thoughtful you are you put up
with hold my likes ass and you're so
reliable and I like I super appreciate
that does not sound like someone you
would describe as a friend oh you're
reliable there's someone who I can count
on you put up with me oh well using the
friendzone relationship he's in a
relationship but even friendzone in that
relationship well you have any thoughts
you want to add no all right well tell
us what you guys think in the comments
below we want to hear your opinion
[Music]
and is there anything I'm convention
about your relationship
I made also we don't have together and
we're non-monogamous yeah what they
don't bang and they don't they're not
monogamous so they're not sticking just
to each other okay word
I think infusing cos people think not
you just go back